Welcome to the lecture on database implementation.
So in the last lecture, we have looked at hashing in general, and then particularly on extendable hashing.
So where we have to store a hash table on disk.
And of course the fundamental problem here that we have is how to grow the hash table.
We saw the classical in-memory solution where we just rehash everything, highly unattractive, because we touch every data item that we have.
And this is of course very, very expensive
if you do this in a random fashion on disk.
And then the idea of extended hash is
that you have a dictionary organized by hash bits
and we use more and more bits as our hash table grows.
And initially in this example, we just use one bit.
And then when we need more space,
we have to distinguish more buckets.
So we double the dictionary by using two bits.
And then we can only update the directory
without updating the buckets.
So we rewrite the directory entry,
but we can just have two pointers pointing
to the same entry here.
And therefore we don't have to rewrite all the buckets,
only the bucket that is overflowing.
So this is all quite good.
And so this is a scheme that indeed can be implemented
on external storage and this works reasonably okay.
Now, one unfortunate thing about extended bashing
that we also mentioned in the lecture last time
we have a very stepwise growth.
So if this is match table size, initially,
I would attach to it small,
then if it's full, then of course we double,
and so if this here is space,
I try to do it like this,
so we double, then for a long time,
we don't do anything,
but then we double again,
then for an even longer time,
we don't do anything,
then we double yet again,
like this,
And then we, yeah, it doesn't fit anymore.
And you see what's happening here.
So we have some extreme steps in growth because of the exponential growth of the Zestable.
And now amortize, this is okay, of course.
So if you amortize over everything, then the cost is not too bad because we don't do this
doubling very frequently.
So it becomes more and more rare the larger Zestable is.
So amortized it's okay, but nevertheless it's very unfortunate if such a step happens.
So if you have to increase the size of a table from 10 million entries to 20 million entries,
so this is a quite expensive step because you must write everything.
And it can of course, can be even higher.
And so it could be that for many seconds, or in worst case even a minute or so,
you wait until the directory is growing.
So you have a very non-linear progress in size.
people unhappy because if you stop your system for many seconds this is not good for user experience
because you have to wait and therefore people have invented or people is not precisely paul
larson or i should say per okla's and it's his correct name from he was later at microsoft but
I think it was still in Waterloo when he invented this.
So he invented linear hashing.
And so this is an external storage scheme
that allows you to,
just like extended hashing,
you grow the directory independent from the buckets,
but we do this in a more graceful manner.
So we don't do this exponential growth step.
how does this look like? So first we start with just like extended hashing looks like this,
since this directory here could also be from extended hashing. So we just have a directory
and points to buckets. Now the interesting question is what happens if we have to grow?
So then extended hashing does not double the directory, instead they double only some of
the entries, which is a bit surprising, but in fact is really possible. So the first,
First when the bucket is full, we do chaining.
So when bucket is full, we do chaining and we say this is okay if the chain is short.
So chaining once we say perhaps it's okay.
But if my chain gets too long or too many buckets have chains, both as possible a criterium,
so then I say no, I must really increase my directory.
So now I must do something.
Okay, and then, so at a certain point here, either triggered by a load factor or by chain
length or something.
So we give ourselves a boundary, then we start a bucket split.
And now what we do is we add the bucket, the new bucket to the directory at the end by
using more bits.
So this looks a bit funny.
So we have a hash table that says, okay, if my two hash bits are 0, 0, I go to B.
If my last hash bit is a 1, it doesn't matter what comes before, I go to C D. And if my
two hash bits are 1 and 0, I go to A E. So here implicitly here is a star.
And as I said, this looks a bit funny, but what happens here is, so this was my starting
table.
Just 0, 1.
have a split marker here that is position k and this k tells me what has been split already.
So initially nothing has been split of course, so we say oh no my k is here, so I have nothing split.
So then if I need space and I decide I split the beginning, so in splitting of course always means
I use one bit more. So now I split this, I use one bit more and as I say here okay,
I use one bit more and what was the other case because now of course there are two cases.
Then at the second case at the end.
Now so we have two boundaries here.
Here this is the width has been split already and this is the old table size.
Now if at some point, so here in the slide you see we say the range from 1 to k has been split,
The range from k to n is unsplit and the range from n plus 2k minus 2, these are the second
half of the split values, this grow at the end.
And so we have split this one entry.
Now if you have to split the bucket with the one again, so in general, if you have to split
again then remove the split marker one step down and then I say okay now I use one bit
more for this bucket too, so now I have 0, 1 here and 1, 1 here.
So now at this point again I have a regular table.
So what I would, if I would do then is I would start again, so with my split marker at the
beginning, nothing is split.
So if I need more space, then I move my split marker here.
I split the, let me clear this, yep.
So I split the 00 into 000 and then of course it gets the partner value here and this is
100.
So now I have split up to here.
The others use one bit less.
So the first bucket uses three bits, the last bucket uses three bits, the other buckets
use only two bits.
Then again, if I need more space, I move further down, so I transform the 0, 1 into 0, 0, 1,
and then I put the corresponding entry here, so then I have split up to here, then I can
need to go split up to here, so I do it like this, 1, 1, 0, if need I go to here, then
I have 1, 1, 1, and then I have a regular table again.
So you always split one entry more.
This causes the total table of course, the directory to grow in a linear fashion.
So we get one entry more.
Instead of doubling all the time, we only add one more entry as we need it.
And yeah, so we split on demand and at some point of course everything is been split and
then we start new.
This is what I have shown you.
Then we have a regular entry.
So and interestingly lookup in such a hash table is actually quite easy because what
you do is you know what is the maximum number of bits that you have, then you compute your
hash value for the maximum number of bits.
And if you happen to end up in this shadow range here that has not been split yet, then
you just fold it here and that's it.
That cost you one if and the one subtraction.
So mapping a hash value to this linear hashing is easy, we just have to compare with n and
then if it is larger than n, we must subtract n.
So this works.
So this is actually not that difficult.
So the nice thing about linear hashing is now we avoid this disruptive directory growth
with extensivating.
Extensivating has these huge steps here, so we small, then large, larger, larger, and so
on.
With linear hashing we grow, of course, as the name says, in a linear fashion, because
we add one entry after the other.
In the end we have the same size, of course, this is not drawn to scale here.
So linear hashing in the end is just as large as extensive hashing, but it should look like
... I didn't draw it perfectly, but you know what I mean.
So in the end, Extendive hashing and linear hashing has the same size.
But in intermediate steps, linear hashing is much smaller, because we don't have to
If we don't have to double, we can grow on demand.
So index grows linearly.
And if we therefore look at the amortized behavior of the index structure, this is very
nice.
Size is good and everything is good.
So these are the good stories.
Now what is bad about linearshing?
As a first, chaining is not so fortunate.
So we don't like to chain.
And because the longer my chain is of course the worse to performances.
but on disk it's even worse.
So chains are not so nice.
And now why are chains a problem?
The problem is, I cannot say,
if you look at this picture here,
I cannot say, or perhaps in this,
I cannot say I want to split this bucket.
It's not possible.
In the linear hedging scheme,
I can only say I want to split the first bucket,
namely this one.
This one I can split.
But this doesn't help me at all,
because the first bucket is not full.
So I split the first bucket,
now to 1 0 0, yeah but didn't help me with the full bucket. Okay then I can go step one step
further, again I split in the bucket but doesn't help me, so I get 1 0 1 and only then is a full
bucket here split. Okay so which means the probability of having a chain is actually
quite high. This is also the reason why they implement chaining. Because some bucket overflows,
but it's not necessarily the next one to split. Of course, if you wait long enough,
at some point in time the split position will come to this chain bucket, so we reach this point.
And then of course everything will be good again, but it can take a while.
So therefore, performance can be degrade, at least for a moment, until we wait for the
split process to reach the bucket that has chaining.
This is one problem, so performance.
The second problem here is, I said so nicely, so we have to start with size 2, so we just
have, I should draw it a bit wider.
So let's make the picture a bit wider.
So I start with just one bit here, that's good.
So then when we need more space, no problem, I add a bucket at the end and then I get a
1 0 and this is of course a 0 0, I need more space here then again, get a 1 1, 1 1, okay
if I need more space then I get here 0, 1, 0, 0 and then I get here 0,
0,
1, 0, 1 and so on. So this gets another zero here. Then if you need more space it's like this,
and then I need more space, it's like this.
So this is messed up the ones.
So this is how it is.
So now on a piece of paper I can easily do this.
I draw this nice picture, and everyone says, yeah, this is nice.
So the table grows linearly, this is good.
How do you implement this?
So how do you implement the data structure that you can grow linearly in size, so that
you can just grow at the end?
If you don't know beforehand how large it will be, of course, I mean if you know how
large it can be, that's easy.
But if you don't know how large it can be, of course the size of the data structure depends
on what data the user inserts and how much data the user inserts, and therefore it's
totally non-obvious how to do this.
the space easily, because it could be pretty large.
And remember this table here, this has to be fit on disk somewhere, which means this
is my disk file, there will be a range in my disk, it's my directory, say from here
to here.
But there can be other data before and other data after.
And at some point this thing here will be full.
And what do I do then?
And actually I asked this Paul Larson, the inventor of the linear heaching.
spoke to him and said, yeah, linear hashing is nice, but how do we implement this?
And he said, yeah, the trick is to forget this picture. So the picture says you do a linear
array here because we say we do a table at the end. And what you do in practice is we do
adjust the tricks that we did with this dynamic XNet mapping. So we chunk the array in reality.
So we have a beginning array and then we reserve more space and more space and so on. So you have
exponential growing things and you fill them from the beginning and and so then we go to a new chunk
here this is of course larger oops this here should be larger i'm running out of bits yeah
so this should be zero zero and then the and and so on yeah so we do it like this
I think I messed up the numbers, no it's not right, there must be four entries here.
And then the next element goes to the next chunk.
So we have exponentially growing chunks, and so then we don't have this allocation problem
because we can dynamically allocate as many chunks as we need and we see how large the
data structure becomes.
But this now costs you one indirection because this means the beauty of a hash table is that
beginning of the pointer and then we just add these two.
So we add the hash table, the hash to the slot, we add it to the pointer jump somewhere.
So this is what we usually do in a hash table.
If you do such a chunking mechanism here, we don't have the allocation problem, but
we can no longer directly jump to an entry.
Instead what we do is we take the hash value, figure out which of these chunks here does
it belong to, then we go to the chunk, we do subtraction and so on.
It's not super expensive because you can decide about which chunk you take
by using this one here, the count leading zeros.
Because we know that the first entries will all have leading zeros,
so we can play some games to figure out where everything should go.
Actually, this would suggest that I should not implement it like this,
but that I should implement it.
I should have chunked them slightly differently.
I should have chunked them.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's not, it's not right.
I know it's okay that I did this.
I know it's okay.
I should just have, I get suboptimal space utilization, but that's okay.
So basically what I do is I put everybody who has the same number of leading zeros in
the same bucket.
So these people here now have ...
Okay, and then, so this has, of course, this has 2, this has 2, and then this has 4, the
next level has 8, and so on.
So if you do it like this, then we can use the number of the count leading 0 function
to figure out in which bucket we have to go.
So we take the mesh value, take count leading 0, so I count the number of 0s that in the
beginning, decide on which bucket I take. I take the point of the bucket, I take the bucket number,
shift the value to the left by the bucket number, and then I subtract this from the value,
and then I know the local offset to which. So it's possible, but it costs you something like
eight instructions or so. And assuming that all the interaction is in memory.
So this means, of course, if you go to disk, that's okay. So because disk is so slow,
extra instructions. But in memory this is quite expensive. So you are very visible if you do this
in memory. Of course if you really go to disk it might be acceptable. But I was just saying here,
it's not impossible to do this, but page allocation for a directive is problematic.
It's not totally obvious how to do this. And whatever choice you do,
cost you something, either space or performance or both.
Now so this is, on a piece of paper linear hashing is easier to implement than in reality.
But nevertheless, this is a viable strategy and I think, I'm not 100% sure, but I think
secret server actually implements linear hashing.
I'm not 100% sure.
I spoke to people from Microsoft about linear hashing, but I forgot to ask if it's in the
So I'm not 100% sure if they do.
But potentially SQL Server has implemented this.
This is definitely a viable strategy for external memory hashing.
But today I also want to look at a third alternative, what we can do to bring hashing
to external memory.
And this is multidevill extender hashing.
So now why are we interested in this?
unfortunately, at least sometimes, our hash values are not as nicely distributed as we might have it.
And so in an ideal world, so if really everything is nicely uniformly distributed,
then our extent of hashing directory is quite fine. So here we see a picture, we use four bits,
so we have 16 buckets, there are 16 slots, each slot points to a bucket, and each entry there are
entries that's fine.
So, but, so this is the ideal word.
Now, unfortunately it can be that some hash values are more frequent than others.
Either because our hash value is poor, so then we can say, of course, use a better hash value.
So if you use a stupid hash value, like, I mean, if you look at, for example, the
Java hash function for strings, that's absolutely terrible, it's an awful hash function.
So don't use this.
If you use such a hash function then it is quite likely that you get skews.
Some hash values are more probable than others and then we have problems.
And now unfortunately this can happen even if you have a great hash function, namely
if you have duplicates.
So poor hash function clearly is a cause of problems, but even good hash functions have
problems if you have real duplicates in the input.
because if two values are the same,
nothing in the world can produce two different hash values from them.
So therefore, fundamentally, some values can be more frequent than others.
And this leads to very unfortunate problems.
Namely, if you then look at the extensive bashing, what happens is that,
here in our example, we assume that these buckets here are frequent.
So we have many, many inserts here, in this range.
The small hash values are frequent.
Therefore, you increase your directory all the time,
All the action happens in this range and the other ranges are always just shared
So this means we have a total of only four
Sorry, it means five totally we have five buckets here
So it's not too much five buckets, but our directory is much larger because many entries point to the same bucket
And if your directory is much larger than your number of buckets, this indicates that you have a problem in your hash distribution
So it could be that your space of the index is dominated by the directory
never happen but should not happen is not the same as does not happen so it should not happen
but it can happen and this is a problem yeah and here the slide says the directory size explodes
and of course if we so if we always insert values they tend to have hash values of so if hash value
hash value is approximately all zeros i mean can be a few bits others but approximately all zeros
then you all end up here yeah and then of course when the bucket is full you split directory so you
But this doesn't really help you because all the other values still have zeros.
And so you still overflow in the left bucket, while the other buckets are very poorly utilized.
And here the slide says that q is an unfortunate reality.
This is unfortunately true.
At least if you lose a lousy hash function, and even with a good hash function, duplicates
are a problem.
So now what can we do about this?
Now one idea of course is to say, I just give up the idea of using a flat hash table, instead
I construct a tree of hash tables.
So you see on the first level I use four bits and then go somewhere.
Now if I realize that my leftmost bucket here, originally I had one, so we go back to this
picture here, we had this bucket and everybody here wanted to insert into this bucket.
And then I realize, okay, I just need more bits for this one bucket here, because so
but if this overflows, I just start using more bits for this bucket.
So I split the bucket and now in this case here I use five bits.
I use one bit more.
And so I have a, I use now a part of my page here.
Again, if this is too small, then I can increase this here to,
within the page I can increase this to 001011.
And then I use now two, four entries and so on.
And so I can use more and more bits.
And of course, if at some point my page is full, but then I just do another level.
So the size of my node here is my page size.
I just make it as large as the page is.
Now clearly building a tree of hash nodes has a disadvantage compared to a classic hash table,
in that the depth is no longer a constant.
So a traditional hash table promises us constant times,
not in reality, might not always happen,
but it promises constant time.
And if you build a tree of hash tables,
and of course, time grows.
But on the other hand,
if I encode it like this,
then I just store a pointer on each entry here.
So which means I have an extremely high fanout.
I have a fanout of 2000 or even more.
So 4,000 depends on how large your page is.
And so we have an extremely high fanout
and therefore my depth will be very low usually.
So usually I don't have to go very deep
until everything fits.
And therefore the additional number of page rows
that you get should be small.
And in addition, we only do this
for the heavily used parts of the index,
which means some parts where we use more bits
is deeper down,
while the parts where we use less dip
is closer to the root.
So we only pay the price
if there's indeed skew in the data.
So this is quite okay.
So a tree of hatchet is okay, but now we get another problem, namely space utilization.
With extended hashing, uniform distribution was the best case for multilevel hashing.
So we just added hash level and now uniform distribution is the worst case.
Now why is this the worst case?
If you have uniform distribution over all buckets, then all buckets will overflow at the same time roughly.
Not really at the same time, of course, but closely after each other all buckets will overflow.
time when all buckets have overflown you have seen something like this.
So you have a directory and then each directory points to another directory where we only use
one bit.
So here we use one bit, here we use one bit, here we use one bit and so on.
So always only use one bit.
And so the second level here will be nearly empty.
This is of course bad, we waste a lot of space and by wasting a lot of space we also waste
performance.
Because if I have empty pages, many of empty pages, then my buffering will not work well.
So my buffer manager will contain a lot of useless data.
So therefore I don't like this.
I want that my pages are filled with useful information.
So this is the problem.
Now, how can we do this?
So instead of giving everybody a new page, we share inner pages using a buddy system.
go back to this picture here and that picture. So we start from the picture in the beginning,
so this is more on initial start here. So then we say, okay, I need everybody uses four bits.
Then I say I need one bit more for this bucket here, for the first bucket, because this bucket
overflows. So now what this schema now does is it says, okay, this first bucket, this was the bucket
that was overflowing, this first bucket gets one bit more and this is this range here on the inner
page yeah but because the rest of the inner page is empty so i don't use it anymore currently
i take all my buddies which means remember these are this is everybody who has the same in this
case the same first bit as i so everybody who also starts with a zero are all my buddies here
and they are also moved to the next level even though strictly speaking they don't need it yet
because they they would be happy with just four bits but they get five bits regardless and this
If you look at this entry, in reality, this points all points to the same next level.
So in reality, they all use the same bucket.
So they don't allocate a new bucket, just conceptually they move to the next level.
So what happens now, of course, is that if in the uniform case, if this bucket here would overflow too,
then we would have no problem because then we could just create a new bucket here and then
move this pointer here.
Same here.
So we now can gracefully overflow all these buckets without doing anything bad,
locally two pointers. Okay, so this is a nice thing. So and of course we can
grow even further. So if we really have skew here, so this bucket is
over again. So far we have used five bits, so five zeros. If now we decide okay we
need six bits and we just split the page again. So we take this inner page, we
split it into half, so this is a half I think, yeah this is half, we split it into
So the right half goes here and the left half goes here.
And now of course we can again split the first bucket that we had and then we here now use
6 bits.
This now uses 6 bits instead of 5.
While my buddies here still means I also use 6 bits but in reality the last two bits don't
matter.
That's because they all point here to the same bucket.
Okay.
And so this way we can get as many bits as we need until of course, at some point we
are, we can continue splitting it.
We can split this here, then split it here.
At some point we are, we are containing the input pointer.
So the input pointer has used all bits on the page.
And then of course we get another level.
So then we would go one level further.
Okay.
But until this happens, we can just split the page and give me locally as many bits as
I need.
And in fact we can do even better because what we realize here, if you look at this picture again, we see that for this range of
buckets here
Everybody points to a new page, but in reality everybody uses no bits from the page
And because I mean conceptually this one here has four bits
But in reality it doesn't matter what value you have you always end up in the same buckets
So it means that you use only four bits and not six even though it looks like you do six
now if you
So if you recognize that everybody in this page does it, then what you can do is you
can fold it back up.
So you remove the page and then you again come to a nice situation.
So we just need one additional page.
And so the good thing is here, so this, this method here uses a buddy scheme, so which
which means the boundaries between buddying entries are always power of the two.
And you can implement this using no extra information.
So this is perhaps a bit surprising that this is possible, but you can implement this by
using just an array of size, in this case, 2 to the power of 4 by 2 to the power of n,
so an exponential sized entry.
And then you just look at the pointers and then you see, for example, here we see, okay,
point to the same page as my neighboring entry.
Therefore, this must be a shared page.
And in fact I also point to the next entry as this one here.
And therefore I know that these four entries share a page, but I do not point to the same
page as ... let me get my bits right ... at this one here.
So this one points to a different page.
that four entries are sharing a page
and therefore everybody here gets two bits
on the next level.
Yeah, and I can infer this by just looking at one,
two, three, four.
And so I've looked at four pointer values
and afterwards I know, okay,
who is sharing the page with me
and how many bits do I get?
And I only have to store the pointer value
to my next page and nothing else.
So I don't say how many bits do you have and so this is all in field.
And also the good thing is the number of elements that you have to look at, in this case 4, is logarithmic.
As you see already that the distance between elements that I have to look at grows a little higher and higher.
This is no surprise.
Because of the budding scheme I can compute the value of the next element that I have to consider.
I just have to check if this points to the same page as I do.
So if this entry would point to the next same page as I do, then I would again make a step
of double size to the right, which in this case would bring me I think here.
So then I would check here, then I would see, okay, do I have to do the point to the same
page or no.
So in the worst case I would have to look at five elements, in my example here I only
have to look at four elements, but never more than five.
So never more than logarithm of the page size.
And so this is pretty elegant because this means you get maximum space utilization.
So what you can do is you can basically store page size divided by the size of a pointer.
So if you do this, so this is a find out that you get.
This is ridiculously high.
So a B tree will have clearly less than this.
So there is an extremely high fanout because we need no extra information.
We can just infer everything from the pointer structure.
This is also written here, this gives me a large fanout.
Also there are some other nice properties, it naturally adapts to data skew, so if some
values are more frequent than others, then you go further down in the tree, otherwise
you don't.
Also directory growth is not a problem here because we have no doubling or anything.
We can just locally split the node that we need, no other problems.
Of course the price that we pay is that we have to have additional page accesses, so
we have to access more than one page.
On the other hand this tree is very shallow usually, and therefore in reality we will
usually not be deeper than let's say two or so.
So therefore the performance here will be quite good.
Okay, now just to mean from an extra level this data structure is quite beautiful and
elegant and so one downside is not written on the slide but I want to mention it regardless
is this is not so easy to implement.
I have been on a piece of paper this looks all beautiful and nice and yeah but let's
Let's say I have implemented this in my younger days.
And yeah, it took me a while to do it correct.
And then I had this fantastic situations where everything worked fully correct for the first
two million inserts and so on.
And then suddenly there's something bad happened because of some folding went wrong or something.
This was not super fun to debug.
So this is definitely a bit more, I mean, even though it's conceptually simple, coding-wise
it's not so simple, this data structure here.
There's not a lot of code, the code is small,
but the code is very subtle, so it's easy to do it wrong.
But conceptually, this is a nice solution to the hashing on disk problem.
So the last index structure that I want to look at are bitmap indexes.
And this is a very particular kind of index,
Namely, these are indexes that are meant to be, or that are useful for cases where the
predicate in itself is unselective.
So this is a bit unusual situation.
Now assume you have, let's say you have two attributes, A or three attributes, A, B, C.
So if you look at the domain of A, then we just have, let's say, two values.
If you look at the domain of B, we have perhaps 10 values.
And if you look at the domain of C, then we have five values.
Now you would never ever construct an index on any of these attributes, definitely never
on A, because if you have, if an attribute where half of the tuppets qualify, then the
index will be much slower than scanning, just scanning the relation.
So building an index on A is not a good idea.
Building an index on B is probably also not a good idea.
I mean, 10 is better than nothing, but still,
I mean, if 10% of your data qualifies,
most likely it's faster to forget the index
and just read everything.
Now, so a B tree on B is probably slower
than just reading everything.
And for C again, most likely,
there are only five different values.
So don't build an index on C.
Now, so this is a usual wisdom.
So if somebody says select star from, sorry, I write it differently.
From R where A equals 5.
So then clearly forget the index, just read R to filter.
That's it.
Now that's faster than the building in the index.
for B2 for B and C. But now what happens if somebody says, I specify A and B, and
so now if you have bindings for A, B and C, then suddenly you might think, I mean, this is,
I mean, if they are statistically independent, you expect that only 1% of the values qualify,
then suddenly it might be attractive to use an index.
So the combination here might be selective enough
that the index is okay.
Yeah, but first, how do you know this beforehand?
So when, and second, how do I answer this?
Of course I could build an index on ABCs
on all three attributes and this would work in this case.
But now if somebody just changes slightly,
says, okay, I don't have a condition on A,
but instead I have a condition on,
let's say on somebody D or something.
so then again um i cannot index every every attribute accommodations so there's the attribute
in in themselves so single attributes are clearly unsuitable for indexing indexing all attribute
combinations is not attractive because they are exponentially many yeah so this is i mean if i have
n attributes you can index two to the power of n combinations and so therefore you don't want this
So, I mean, if I would know beforehand that I would always search for ABC and only ABC,
I can solve this with a B-tree too.
But if there are output combinations that can occur and I don't know beforehand what
I can do, then traditional indexes like B-trees or even worse, hash indexes, they are unsealable.
And bitmap indexes are made for this.
So they are made for cases where we also have to handle unproductive indexes.
And so this is just what I said.
So it could be that we have predicates
that return large fractions of the tuples.
Then index excess is more expensive than tables can.
And then we don't do this.
And now a combination of predicates might be selective.
Now what you could do is in principle,
you could do index intersection,
it's probably cheaper than just lookup and picture.
So intersection means you read one index here.
So this gives you a lot of tuple IDs.
do not look up the tablets themselves.
You just fetch the tuple IDs.
Fetch the tuple IDs.
Then we use an index on B.
We also fetch the tuple IDs.
And then we do intersection.
Now this we can do,
the easiest way is you sort them and do intersections.
This is then of course a cheap intersection,
but the sorting is expensive.
Or you will dash table from the smaller side.
Yeah, you do something like this.
So you intersect the tuple IDs.
And then once you've found all tuple IDs
that occur for all predicates,
look up at the real, real tuples.
Okay.
So there are situations where in the exception is a viable strategy,
but nevertheless, it's quite expensive.
Well, this intersection operation itself is not very cheap.
Then to fetch the final tuples, you probably have to sort the tuple IDs again to avoid random
Mio.
So this is all pretty expensive.
And even worse, there are other nasty things you can do.
Like you can say, for example, I want that A and B, that's okay.
Or C. Or is an operation that database systems don't like.
In general, ors are evil.
So or is a very unfortunate operation.
So we don't like ors.
or unpleasant, but for indexes in particular,
how should you answer an all with an index?
And we can do this intersection, but all,
of course we can do union,
what you could do is you do union and duplicate elimination,
but this is not very attractive.
So this is disjunction is bad.
All the other bad things are,
I mean, I get the example that a equals five.
What about the example b not equals six, so not equal.
This is also unpleasant to do with an index.
I mean, you can answer all the predicates with a B tree.
You can, but usually not very efficiently.
Yeah.
Even though not equal, you can answer because not equal, of course, mean is the same and
not equal 6, of course means B is less than 6 or B is larger than 6.
Yeah.
Therefore you can do this with two range queries.
You read everything up to 6 and everything beyond 6 and you union this, then you give
the result.
but you can answer this, but this will often be inefficient.
And now Bitmap index has promised
that they can do this right.
So, and how does this work?
So first, we usually only built an index
if my domain is reasonably small,
which means that I have only few possible values,
like 10 or perhaps 20 or so,
but not if you have 10,000.
So then probably you do not want to use a Bitmap index.
So Bitmap index you use with a small domain.
And then what you do is you look at all possible values that you have.
Here we see for example, this is a bitmap here for a equals 2.
And then for every tuple that we have in my database, we store a 1 in there if the predicates
true and a 0 if the predicates false.
So here we see the first tuple a is 2, second tuple a is not 2, third tuple a is not 2,
for the fourth tuple a is 2 and so on.
So we have a long sequence of ones and zeros.
And this is the same for all other values.
See, like if we check for a is three,
for the first tuple it's not true, obviously,
because it has the value to,
for the second tuple it is true,
then it's not true, not true and so on.
So we built a large bitmap
and we built a bitmap for every possible value.
And now once we have these indexes,
the index intersections,
so figuring out which values qualify,
just become bit operations.
Now because if we,
of course with a doesn't make sense,
obviously this one but let's assume this here some other values like b equals 5 or so then if
you want to check that a equals a equals 2 and b equals 5 this boils down to just doing a bitwise
and now so you take the two bitmaps you do bitwise and of both and the positions where
one remains then you have a match okay and this you can do without very many so
you have many predicates even though each index is unselected if you just do a
linear pass over the index do bitwise and and then the result tells you okay
here we have an hit here we have a miss now if you want to do it not in an end
but if you want to do an all then of course it works just the same the only
you don't do in bitwise end, we do in bitwise all.
So it works just the same.
Also if now we would say we want that b, we say a is 2 and b is not 5, so then we say,
this of course boils down to bitwise end and you negate the right hand side.
So this is also again two bit operations.
So basically we take the index for b equals 5, we negate the bitmap, so we flip all the bits.
So 1 becomes 0, 0 becomes 1, we flip all the bits, then we do bitwise AND, and then this gives me again the position of all the hits.
So this is super cheap.
You don't need a hash table, you don't need a sword, nothing.
You just do bitwise operation, and of course with one bitwise operation we can most likely process 64 entries if you have a 64-bit machine.
So this intersection is very, very, very cheap.
Okay.
And so the bitmap is quite compact.
We need one bit per tuple.
Now, so here is next by the point it says,
potentially we might need one entry more
as the tuple ID directory.
So, because here I said first entry is tuple ID one,
second ID tuple ID two.
This only works if you have dense tuple IDs.
If you don't, then we need one extra column,
which lists all tuple IDs.
Yeah, so, but this can be shared for all indexes.
So we just store one array with all table IDs,
if you need this.
Okay.
And so,
so spatialization is not that bad.
And furthermore, what we see is
this bitmap indexes tend to be sparse,
which means that most entries tend to be zero.
Now there are far fewer ones than zeros in there.
And therefore what you can do is we can compress them.
And also we don't store the whole vector,
but we compress the vector.
What we easily do is we just use run length encoding,
which means we say here we have a vector where we say,
okay, now you have real ones and zeros,
so one, zero, one, zero, one.
Okay, and then we say, okay,
now comes here one million zeros,
and then comes the next vector of hits.
And so on.
Yeah, so we compress away the zeros.
We say here now I have a long run of zeros.
and the good thing about this formula is that these if we can still perform intersection on
the compressed form without decompressing now because if the right hand side says okay i have
perhaps start similar says that start instead i do this one then here i do a bitwise and of course
then it says i have 500k zeros and then have another bit of a vector and then have perhaps
So the first entry here I do a real intersection.
Then I compare this and this and then see oh no hit.
So I skip over 500,000.
Then I have used the first half million here, the next half million is remaining.
Then I look at this block, see it cannot be a hit because the other side is all zeros.
So therefore I skip over the block two, then I advance my conceptual pointer here a bit,
then I compare it with this one and so on.
That's why I skip over both, read both lists sequentially and I skip over the compressed ranges.
So this can be implemented very efficiently.
Then people have written papers on how to do this with SIMD instruction and so on.
So we can do a very fast intersection of compressed bitmaps.
And once you have this, then you see that very often this is much faster than other indexes,
if you have unselective attributes.
for selective attributes like a primary key,
then it doesn't make sense to use a bitmap index.
For selective attributes, use a real index.
But if you have unselective attributes,
where only the combination of attributes is selective,
then bitmap indexes are quite attractive.
So they work very well.
In fact, they are more or less the only known option
in such a situation.
And so nobody has found a better solution to this problem.
So when we have a large number of attributes
where users can query for arbitrary combinations,
you don't know it beforehand,
in itself is unselective, then bitmap indexes are usually the method of choice.
And commercial database systems also offer bitmap indexes, I think all of them, at least most of
them, probably all of them, offer bitmap indexes. So these are also vitally supported just for this
use case. Okay, now about nearly the last indexing techniques that I want to look at is
particular kind is not really an index I mean some people call this lightweight
indexing but anyway it's not really an index this is something that the inventor
Guido Mocotto has called small materialized aggregates okay now what is
the idea of this you say I mean very very often you have chunks of values
anyway either for example if you have a single page now a page might be too small for this
but then perhaps you have a run of pages like you say i have on my physical storage i have here a
number of pages that you store and or if your page is large then you can even do it on a single page
and now what you could do is you could in the beginning of your block you store something is
something that is very small it doesn't take a lot of space and this is useful for processing and
this is what he called small material as aggregate now what you could store for example if you have
a relation r this contains attributes a and b but you could store for this chunk here is you look at
both attributes and b and you store for each value attribute here these values here so from here to
here so the smallest a 10 the largest a 20 the sum of all your a's and the number of a values that
Okay.
And this works, I mean, it can be due for this for arbitrary
attributes, but this works particularly well for if the
attribute is like something like a date or so.
Now why is, or it doesn't have to be a date.
A date is a good value, but date is not necessarily
the only one.
Another good field for this kind of operation here is,
for example, an ID field that is monotonically growing.
And also like if students come, they get a student ID
student ID grows monotonically.
And now what happens is there's a physical storage
usually mimics insertion order roughly,
not perfectly because we filled space and so,
but roughly insertion order mimics,
a physical storage mimics insertion order,
which means if your field is monotonically growing,
like an ID field or a date field or so,
this means that here we tend to have small values.
It's not perfect, but we tend to have small values
time and here we tend to have the large values.
So this just happens because of the nature of the data that we insert.
And now if you look at this momentous aggregates here, if somebody says, for example,
so this is the data that we have and somebody says, I've stored this for a block,
somebody says select star from R
where A is equal to let's say 50.
Then when we come to this block,
we can immediately say we will have no hit in the block.
Yeah, because we know that the smallest value is 10,
the largest value is 20, 50 is outside of this range.
Therefore we can just forget the block
and skip the whole block
So we just skip over everything here.
Now we can do even more than this.
For example, if somebody says, so this is the case where nothing qualifies.
Second example here is select star from R where A is larger than 5.
Now we see everything qualifies.
We don't even have to check the condition
because we know for sure all this here is very qualified.
So we don't even look at the tuppets.
And we can do even more than just
return all the tuppets.
Like if somebody goes even further than this,
select some A from R where A equals five.
We can answer this question here
without looking at the single value in my block.
Yeah, because I know the sum must be 1500.
I've pre-computed this.
I've pre-computed the sum.
Now, if I know that all my tablets qualify, I can answer this question, at least for this
block.
Of course, now, remember we store the full chunks of data, so I have this data chunk,
I store the aggregate, I have that data chunk, small the aggregate, small the data chunk,
and so on.
And what will happen is I look at all the chunks, I look at my query, I look at the small materials
aggregate at the beginning, and then I can, for example, say, this block will never qualify,
just skip it, don't do anything.
This blocker will fully qualify,
then we can, so everything will be a match.
Then we can extract the sum, for example, from here.
And we can not only answer sum,
we can also answer, for example, average,
because if you know, it also works,
because we know that my sum is 1,500,
the count is 1,000, therefore the average is 1.5.
And so I know this, this fully qualifies.
And then for example,
you could say this here partially qualifies.
then here we look at the real values in themselves.
Okay.
So we, we, we use this data and now this works for two reasons.
First, as I said, insertion order corresponds to physical storage and we tend to have trends
in the data, IDs grows, dates grow.
So this kind of thing.
And therefore if a query goes on this edge, this works well.
And the second reason why this works well is data tends to be static once it has a
been inserted for a while.
So when the insert data, it might change in the next few minutes or so.
But once the data has been in the database system for a few days and has not been changed,
most likely it would never change until it will be deleted perhaps at some point.
But data that has been inserted in the database and is in the database for a while, it very
often has never changed or is rarely changed.
So therefore my data remains tends to be static and therefore this aggregate just works fine.
So we can pre-compute this aggregate and just keep it.
Now if somebody really up to us doesn't update in my block, so this is my block of tuples,
I have now for this block computed minimum is 10, maximum is 20, some is this one, count
is this one.
Now somebody doesn't update here.
Then of course these attributes are no longer true.
So but what what we just do is we set a flag say this is invalid
And we don't do anything if you just maxes it will it no more updates come more updates come more updates come
yeah, so now and at some point a query comes and
Note that this query would look at all the tuples anyway
Yeah, because my small materials aggregates
It doesn't help me because it's invalid. So therefore as a clearly we look at this this block of values anyway
the moment that you read the block we recompute the small materials aggregate so this is just
like a cache so when the query comes we compute min max sum and count and then we can refresh the
small materials aggregate and then it's valid again for the next query okay so this works
beautifully because it's so simple it's a very simple scheme you have no fancy tree structure
so just a few values since you store at the beginning of your block can be stored cheaply
can be cleared easily.
Of course, it's not as powerful as a real index
because we can all do this
finger, min and max here,
but it's very cheap and very easy to implement.
Yeah, so this is what I said.
Before we scan a chunk, we examine the aggregate.
And if we can decide about the predicate
based upon the aggregates,
then we can skip the chunk fully
and then we never read it.
Okay?
And if we update and we invalidate and recompute,
either eagerly or lazily.
Most likely you want to do it lazily.
So you've recomputed when the first query comes
because the query would have read everything anyway.
So we recomputed, but when we do the update,
we don't do anything.
So it works beautifully.
And for this reason, in fact, many,
I would perhaps even say most database systems,
at least the data warehouse systems,
So the systems that are optimized for analytical queries on large amounts of data
They probably have all or so at least to a large extent implemented some variation of this
Just because it's bang for the buck is right here. So it's pretty easy to implement and you can save a lot of
Effort very often and if you cannot save anything because it could be that all your queries
In the range doesn't help you at all, but nevertheless it's cheap. Yeah, so you cost you two ifs
For a large block of tupper, this is nothing.
So the check is very cheap.
So we can just do it even if it doesn't help us either.
And if it does help, then we save a lot of effort.
Okay, so now the very last slide here on indexing.
This is about multidimensional indexing.
And I just want to spend one slide on this.
I think this is what I want to say.
Now you could spend a whole semester on this.
huge field. So there are tons of papers on different approaches that you can do.
And so first perhaps to just clarify what do we mean is multi-dimensional indexing.
So far our indexing was one-dimensional because we could, we have one dimension,
for example we have an attribute x and we could ask of course for x equals 5 or we could also say
x is within the range of let's say 3 and 7. So this is a one-dimensional query.
Now it could be that you have two attributes, x and y, and you want to know, is my pair
x, y in the range, let's say 3 to 7, 10 to 20.
So two-dimensional queries, all the other things we can ask.
But this is the most simple two-dimensional query.
We give a range for two attributes, please find me all values that fall into this range.
Now this is a two-dimensional query.
Of course you can have it more,
you can also have three dimensions or even further.
So the number of dimensions that you can have
can be quite high.
And people use this also for all kinds of things.
Like for example, if you do a multimedia retrieval,
so you want to find the pictures
that are similar to other pictures.
What people do is they extract features from the picture
and then they do a multi-dimensional query
that says give me all other pictures
that are close by to my query point in the dimension space.
Usually it is a high dimensional query,
so there are many dimensions.
And so there is an incredibly high number
of approaches that we can use.
Yeah, you can, for example, just to give you some names,
if you can use an R tree, or we can use,
just to, I didn't even put it here,
you can use a KD tree,
or we can use a grid file, we can use a pyramid scheme,
we can say forget about this multi-managing indexing stuff.
We index each output individually
and then we just intersect this.
So there are tons of approaches that we can use.
By the way, now just to give a high level idea
what these things here are doing.
So basically what, for example, what this archery does,
Let's say, okay, everything here is in this rectangle,
everything here is in that rectangle,
and then we built a tree out of bounding rectangles.
Yeah, and then of course could be, could be,
could go further down.
Now so, and so when we, when we query, we figure out, okay,
which rectangle does my query rectangle intersect with,
and then we traverse down and all the rectangles,
and then we retrieve all the, all the bits.
And also, there are, you say, hundreds of approaches, probably too little, probably
there are thousands of approaches.
And I don't want to discuss them here for two reasons.
First mean, it just is beyond the scope of this lecture.
So there are specialized lectures that talk about this.
I think our sister university, the LMU, has lectures on high-dimension indexing.
So you can spend a ton of time on this.
the another very fundamental unfortunate thing about multi-dimensional indexing is
it doesn't work okay now this might be a bit too strong a word two-dimensional indexing is
usually fine three-dimensional indexing is probably also okay four yeah perhaps and so
the problem is the higher the number of dimensions that you have the worse the performance of the
indexes yeah so if you can index one dimension is no problem two dimensions also reasonably okay
And the more dimensions you have, the worse it becomes.
And now what is the highest number of dimensions that you can index?
It's hard to say, depends on the distribution of your values and so on.
We cannot say it easily, but as a rough rule of thumb, you can say you can index perhaps
six dimensions okay.
If you have more than six dimensions, you most likely have problems.
And if you have more than 10 dimensions, you can be pretty sure that the indexing doesn't
work.
Now, what means doesn't work?
You would be better off to forget your index read everything and just filter on the values that you have
Yeah, and this is so called a curse of dimensionality
And also then we have a low number of dimensions everything is okay
But the highest number of dimension that we have so verse everything becomes yes
So scan becomes faster than in extra in fact there was a
pretty a nice paper that not that in fact proved this
So this is not just a problem of implementation that people didn't find good indexes, but
then it is fundamentally impossible to do this without extra information.
Sometimes we know something about the distribution of data and the queries and we can handle
even high dimensions well.
But if you don't know anything, so if you index arbitrary data, then high dimension indexing
for high dimensions is fundamentally impossible.
And the reason is that the highest number of dimension is that you have the more similar
the distance between data points becomes.
So as the number of dimension grows, the difference between, the distance between data points
shrinks.
Now just if you look at the formula here, so the formula says of course, my distance function
here is I take the n square root of the sum of the distance. So query i minus delta i.
And so if you have Euclidean distance here. So this is the Euclidean distance. And as n grows,
the values that you get tends to become more and more the same. And so the distance,
difference between distances grows down.
And this unfortunately means that indexing
at some point just doesn't help you.
So the discriminative power of the index goes away.
So the index can no longer distinguish elements
that are close by or that are far away.
So we cannot do this anymore.
At least in the general case, we cannot.
And therefore multidimension indexing
is a very sad topic.
I mean, if the dimension is multidimensioned
with a low number of dimensions, okay.
It doesn't work that way.
And therefore I don't want to talk about this on the lecture.
So I concentrated here on one dimension indexes and that's it.
And they work of course.
But higher dimensions, if you want to look at this, you have to look at the literature.
Now just one point for clarification.
I always said one dimension is okay.
Didn't we say you can build an index on let's say a comma b?
Don't we say this?
So b tree, create index.
and yeah, but this is still one dimensional.
It looks two dimensional, but it doesn't
because if we sort them less geographically,
and so we treat this as one value
and we define a total order for the compound here.
And so because of this,
because of you having the total order,
this is in fact a one dimensional query,
even though we give it two attributes.
The perhaps obvious reason why this is one dimensional
is in this such a situation,
for a and b you can query for a but you cannot query for b yeah this great index you cannot
query for b because this is a one-dimensional index in a two-dimensional index you could
query for b yeah because then we would say we could form outer rectangles and say give
me everything this is in this in this rectangle which in particular means we can shrink a
to a point and then just have a b so we or no sorry the other way around so we can we
We can expand a from plus to minus infinity and just have b on a specific point and then
we can do a search for a specific value of b.
Because this is one particular rectangle.
So with multi-dimensional indexes we can query for outer algebraic combinations between the
regular indexes that we use in the database systems we cannot.
So, multi-dimensional indexes are more powerful than single-dimensional indexes.
Only problem is they don't work very well.
So performance is la la.
Depends on the use case of course.
There are some use cases where they work just fine.
In the arbitrary case, they don't work that great.
Okay, so this brings me to the end of this large part about storage and indexing and
And the next part that I want to look at is transactions and recovery.
Now, some of you might attend my lecture on transaction systems and there are some overlap
here to this, but it's only minor. I mean, there's some overlap because I want to repeat the
definitions. You might also know them from your introduction to databases lecture. If you did this,
hopefully you did this. So I taught this also in my introductory course, but we only do this in
the beginning to speak about what we mean with transactions and recovery and so on.
But of course what we are interested in later is how to implement this.
Because after all this is an implementation lecture here.
So this is usually not covered in the other lectures.
So the next few slides might be a repetition for you.
But afterwards we talk about implementation.
This is most likely new.
Okay, so now when we look at database systems,
we see database systems offer two important concepts here first
we have transaction support which means we can
combine a sequence of operations into compound operations so we can just say okay please begin here and then do a number of steps and then we finish here and then we
know that
this compound thing that we have defined is executed with well-defined semantic and of course we will see in a moment
how
what we mean with well-defined.
And what the data system also offers,
and this is actually closely related
both conceptually and in implementation,
it also offers you a recovery component,
which says if your database crashes,
or the machine crashes, or the operating system crashes,
or network crashes, or anything crashes,
so at any point in time,
then the system is in a very well-defined state.
So it means the system is in a consistent state
afterwards and no committed data is lost.
So if you brought there some sort of database
and the database says system said yes,
then this is never lost.
Even though if it crashes a millisecond later,
that's okay, we still have the data.
And so committed data is never lost
and data is always in a consistent state.
And now this of course is related
to the transaction concept because it could be
that my crash here happens in the middle
of such a compound operation here.
here and then i must still make sure that even though my operation was not finished yet i did
some part of what i wanted to do but not everything now still the database must be in a consistent
state afterwards yeah and oops sorry and um because in reality these two concepts are closely related
also in implementation so when we implement transaction support we must most likely know
how recovery works and the other way around when we implement recovery most likely we must know
works in the system.
Therefore, we consider both of them together here
in one chapter, because it's really closely related.
Now, as an obvious example here,
so why do we care for transactions?
People understand this well when we talk about money.
So assume you want to move money from bank account A to B.
So we read the balance of A into a variable.
So this is what we do here.
So we do the read,
a by 50 because we want to take 50 from the bank account.
We write back a, so then we read the bank account b into a variable, we update b with
50 and then we write b here.
And so this is a very basic transaction that we have and of course we want for example
that the money is never lost.
So assume hypothetically that we would crash at this point in time so then 50 was reduced
from a but 50 was not added to b.
This of course is the problem, we want that the money is never lost.
It must be done correctly.
So we must handle crashes.
We must handle concurrency because it could be that
there's not only one user moving money around,
but multiple users.
But here we have copied our A to a local variable.
So what does this mean?
So this is a problem and so on.
And so crashes, correctness and concurrency
are all issues here and they must all be tackled.
And the transaction concept that we have offers us this.
So database system, if you offer us ACID transactions,
they solve all these kinds of problems that we have.
And the interface, of course, from the outside is,
so we begin the transaction at some point.
So either explicitly by saying in secret, begin transaction.
So then we say, please start now.
Or sometimes systems just begin a transaction implicitly,
like you connect to the database,
then immediately you have a transaction.
So then you have it.
And then you perform a number of operations
and your transaction finishes,
So by integral you say quit or you abort.
So then says your transaction fails.
And secretly you do this with a rollback statement.
And in the commits case,
you write everything that you did in transaction to disk.
So to permanent storage.
And this is never lost again.
So if the commit comes back and says yes,
then your changes must be stored in a persistent manner.
if you do a rollback then all changes that you did are removed so they are undone so then
the system looks like if you never did anything in your transaction so this is semantic now a commit
you always do yourself by sending a commit a rollback might be triggered externally for example
if you lose your connection to the database for some reason then implicitly your transaction rolls
Because obviously you cannot send a commit any longer when your network connection goes
down.
Therefore, this is an implicit rollback.
And you might other things like an error occurs or somebody cancels your query or something
else.
So rollbacks can occur for a number of reasons.
Commits only because you send them a commit.
By the way, an interesting property in this context here is because of this property here,
a rollback must always succeed.
A commit can fail for a number of reasons,
like the system might recognize
that you do something invalid,
so you violate some constraints,
or more basic reasons like disk is full,
so you cannot write the data.
Then a commit fails, but an abort must never fail.
Because as I said, you can abort,
because the network connection goes down
and you cannot prevent this.
The database system cannot prevent
the network connection from going down,
always succeed as you cannot, you cannot refuse a rowback.
Okay. And this you're hopefully all know
from your introductory lecture.
So is it transactions should offer ACID properties.
ACID means atomicity.
So all operations are either executed completely
or not at all.
Consistency, a transaction brings a database instance
from one of consistent state into a consistent state.
I, it means isolation.
So the database gives us the illusion as if we are the only user of the system.
And this greatly simplifies our life, of course, because we don't have to worry about concurrent
users.
We are the only users in the system.
At least it looks like it's very the only user.
In reality, we are not.
But it looks like if we are the only user in the system.
And D, durability.
Once a transaction commits successfully, a change is never lost.
It doesn't matter what happens.
So crashes, disk foils, whatever, data must never be lost once it has been committed.
These are the so-called ACID properties.
And the ACID properties make using a database system of course much, much easier.
Because all the difficult problems of concurrency and error handling have been solved for you
via the database system.
And now the concept of recovery in the database system is closely related to this transaction
Yeah, because a database system must handle a crash
in an arbitrary point of time.
So this means of course two things.
First, the database structure itself must survive a crash.
Like it must not be that if you crash
and come back again, the database system says,
oh, file corrupt, too bad, go away.
As this must not be the case.
So we must survive this.
And second, we must still offer the transaction guarantees.
So for atomicity, this means that if you had an in-flight transaction in the moment that
a crash happened, then we must roll back the changes that have already been performed.
So when the database system comes back again, we must remove everything that has been done
by transactions that have not committed yet.
For consistency, we must say consistency and guarantees must still hold even though we
crash, we must still get a consistent database.
and last year durability.
Once we have been committed,
we must never lose it data,
even though the data might still be in transient memory.
So it could be that somebody wrote something
as a stored something database,
you hold it in memory currently.
You have not written it to disk yet
because it's sitting in your buffer manager.
Now the buffer manager has the data,
but the buffer manager has not written it to disk yet.
Now a crash happens and you lose all your memory.
Like you have a power failure.
And power failure is very unpleasant.
a power failure so you cannot do anything memory is gone nevertheless you must not lose the data
because the user gave us a commit and we promised him durability therefore we must preserve this data
okay and of course we will look at techniques how to guarantee this
and as for the last point the dependencies is mutual in fact so for isolation here the
dependency is usually the other way around so some database systems use the recovery component that
we have anyway.
So the recovery component we need for this reasons here, in particular for A and D. For
this and this we need recovery.
And because you have the recovery component, some systems use the recovery component to
implement isolation.
We also will talk about this.
So therefore, this is really closely interlinked, the concept of transactions.
So transaction is visible to the user, recovery is not visible to the user, it's internally
in the database system, but these two concepts are closely related in the implementation.
Okay, and so the two logical concepts of transactions and recovery are on a technical
level usually split into two parts that again are interlinked, but they are nevertheless,
so there are different implementations for both. The one component is what we call a concursory
control and this is mostly responsible for um for offering i and c so transaction isolation and
consistency this is done by concurrency control and the second component that we have is logging
and this is usually mostly responsible for atomicity and durability i say mostly because it's not
completely true some people use the logging facility for isolation too yeah so but but
but roughly we can map them like this.
Now so Kocococ control is responsible
for transaction isolation
and logging is for atomicity and durability, mostly.
Okay, and so this is also now what we would want to look at.
And so clearly what we want in a database system,
we want that the database system is used by multiple users
because if we only allow a single user in the system,
then everything is slow.
No, because in the worst case, somebody does the following.
We connect, then we do select one.
Okay, one is perhaps too stupid.
Select star from R.
Perhaps even say begin.
Then we look at the result and then we say,
mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm, surprising, surprising.
then we here walk away and fetch some coffee yes because i have to think about this so now we are
spending here like we are waiting here for five minutes or ten minutes until he comes back and
then after we have thought about the problem for five minutes then we then we do perhaps an update
statement or another select yeah so which means a transaction can take a long time if users involved
I mean most transactions are short because usually a program connects to
database, sends us a transaction, get an answer, closes the connections, keeps
connection open, but at least commits or roll it back. So then the connection
takes a short period of time. Most of the transactions are this kind, but it's
not the only ones. So it could be that a transaction runs for a long time
because for example, here we are waiting for a user input. So then it takes a
It could be that the transactions are slow.
So because we are running a big query
and then we have to wait for disk.
So we must read data from disk.
Therefore, transactions can take seconds or even minutes.
And if a transaction takes minutes,
then serial execution,
so meaning running one transaction after the other
is clearly not an option.
Because otherwise somebody could send me one statement,
we wait and until this statement is gone,
everybody else would have to wait.
This is unacceptable.
We want that many people can use the database system
Okay, so therefore what we want is concurrent execution.
And so we want that many people
access the database simultaneously.
Unfortunately, this is concurrent execution
is good for performance, bad for correctness.
I mean, bad is too strong,
but there are problems that can arise.
Here's a classical one here, lost update.
So what we see here is transaction one reads X,
transaction two reads X, transaction one,
writes X, transaction two writes X,
and then both commits.
is here that this write here is lost.
Yeah, because here at this point,
transaction one wanted to write something to X.
Transaction two didn't even see this
because transaction two performed the read before the write.
And so the read was before the write
and this write was before that write.
Therefore this write of T1 was overwritten by T2.
And because T2 didn't realize
that somebody else was stating the same data.
And this of course is a terrible event
because this now leads to inconsistent data.
If you think about the example of moving money
from bank account A to B,
so it could be that this change here was,
I reduce A by X, let's call it X,
I reduce here X by 10, this here reduces X by 20.
So what you want is the final result reduces X by 30,
but this is not what's happening.
because of the override, the final result is just reduced by 20.
Now in this particular example, you might be happy because if this is your bank account
and you have 10 euro more than you expected, you might be glad.
But it could also be the other way around, two people try to deposit money on your bank
account.
So instead of doing a minus, you want to do a plus.
And then of course you are unhappy because now suddenly you lost 20 euros that you would
like to see on your bank account, but don't.
So therefore lost updates are clearly a terrible problem.
We don't want this.
There are also other problems that are perhaps not as terrible as lost update, but they are
also still pretty terrible.
So this is for example a dirty read.
So dirty read means you read something that has never existed, like transaction 1 starts,
transaction 2 starts, updates x here.
Then transaction 1 reads x and this point we see, ah, we see this right, therefore we
see this value, then transaction 1 says okay, if x is this and I can update y like that,
then we commit.
Here at this point in time, when we commit,
and commit comes back, we promise durability,
which means we write it to disk and we never forget it.
But what happens later is what T1 never sees is T2 aborts,
which means that this write here is undone.
Therefore my read saw values that never existed
in the database, at least conceptually.
It did never exist in the database.
We saw an invalid value.
This means now we have written an invalid value
into the database.
This is of course very bad.
read can also lead to inconsistent data and outer bad things bad now if you go further down in the
hierarchy of bad things this is again perhaps a bit less bad than um than um than a dirty read
and non-repeatable read here so what happens is transaction reads data and the data is
consistent everything's right but the data changes and I like here T1 reads X
then sometime passes to two updates X and commits T1 reads X again at this
point in time you see a different value of X as you to see different values of
X and even though T1 did not update X in itself this of course is a violation of
transaction isolation because if transactions are isolated from each
So the database system should give us the illusion that we are the only user on the system
This is clearly not the case because the data value changes magically behind our back. Yeah, this should never be possible
so, um, it's it's committed and perhaps it's even consistent, but
It's changes this is bad
And you know implicitly this can even reach to inconsistent data
It is not only surprising the transaction can even reach any consistent data because
if you think about this, t1 might be doing something large.
Like we might do something like we aggregate r1, then we join this with r2 and then we
perhaps, then we do perhaps another join here, r3 and then we join this with another aggregate
of r1.
So now you see that we read r1 twice, but if you have a non-repeatable read, it can happen
that this r1 here gets a different, we see here, different r1 than we see here.
And then of course my joint results don't match together, so totally bogus results can
happen because I mean, I expect that these base sets are the same, but it could be that
they are not.
And then yeah, the query can produce arbitrarily bad results.
that give you totally wrong results
just because of this problem of non-repeatable reads.
And so the last of the classical anomaly
that we want to look at is a so-called phantom problem.
So this is perhaps the most harmless
of the problems that we have seen,
but at the same time as the most difficult to prevent,
which is the unfortunate combination.
And so it's not so super pressing,
but it's very difficult to prevent.
we have here as follows.
So you say, select count star from R.
So you read everything from R.
So then somebody inserts a new tuple
in my relation and commits.
And then again, I count everything from R.
Now here you see a different count.
Now see here we see one plus one.
So I get a different number.
Now you might ask, what is the difference
between a non-repeatable read and a phantom?
Isn't that the same?
No, it's not exactly the same.
With non-repeatable read,
certain value, for example, a tuple or some attribute value, we have a certain value in my
database and if I read this particular value twice, I get a different result. And this is clearly a bad
thing. But this is not what's happening here. In a phantom, we have a tuple that did not exist the
first time. So here it could be the first time here we have just had one tuple and of course we
could read this tuple and this tuple doesn't change. But then when the insert comes, a new tuple is
inserted and if i would just do a point query so let's say if i would say select star from
from r where
pk equals five and i did see the value the first time if i didn't see then
even this can have a problem but if i did see this value the first time then i'm not affected
by phantom problem because there's a value here i got it i will always get it over and over because
if there's no non-repeatable reads this value is safe all the time but if i not do a point access
but if i do instead do a range queries like here we say give me all tuples then suddenly new tuples
show up and this might make you unhappy too depending on your semantic yeah so of course
this is probably less bad than having a non-repeatable read, but nevertheless, it's unfortunate.
And on a technical side, this is surprisingly difficult to prevent. Meaning we will talk
about the implementation of this in the next lecture, but just saying, I mean, a traditional
solution, for example, is locking. Like if you read something, you remember, this was a tuple
a read please don't modify it until i'm done this way you prevent a non-repeatable read for example
so you just remember that somebody has read the value yeah but this locking does not help you
with phantoms because in the first time you performed this read here so this read the phantom
tuple obviously did not exist yeah and you cannot lock something that does not exist
therefore locking does not help you with phantoms at least a naive locking does not
Now, so fandoms are surprisingly hard problem.
Okay, and so now clearly all the problems
that we have seen on the previous slides
would go away if you would execute transactions serially.
So we would join after these others
because then no problems are possible.
But this we don't want because of the problems
that we mentioned, we have poor performance.
We wait for users, this is terrible.
So therefore what we want instead is,
transactions are executed as if they were serial.
Yeah, so they should behave as if you would execute it
serial, even though in reality we don't.
And so this concept is called serializability.
So you want that it's the schedule is serializable,
which means it behaves as if you would have done it
in a serial manner.
And to guarantee this, we require some bookkeeping.
Okay, now I see that I'm running out of time.
So I will stop here now.
I will talk about the implementation of all these mechanisms here in the next lecture.
Okay.
Thank you.